rural England on the coldest day of the
year so far Picture Perfect Villages but
for some increasingly rustic living
standards
Saint Mary's Church is opening its doors
every week during winter for those
seeking warmth comfort and Company in
uncertain times everybody is affected
we've had it so easy up till now you
know you've turned the tap that's been
hot water
and you've had money to pay your bills
and you turn the heating on and it's and
we've been very very lucky in this
country very lucky and we've always made
help others now we need the help
across the country thousands of public
buildings are being turned into
so-called warm Banks where people can go
to heat up for free especially if they
can't afford the soaring cost of energy
bills which have doubled it's down to
Charities businesses and Community
groups to step in amid a worsening cost
of living crisis
this is an affluent part of the country
chocolate box England but this crisis is
affecting a broader spectrum of people
than ever before everyone is getting
poorer everyone's wages are being
squeezed and everyone's costs are going
up and for those people who've been just
about managing money couldn't be any
Tighter and now increasingly poverty is
embedded within communities
warm banks operate on the same Principle
as food banks like this volunteer Joe
Payton is packing Surplus Goods destined
for people who can't afford to feed
themselves or their families we've seen
I guess the last month is we're seeing
people that are working or people who've
been on benefits but they've coped and
now they've got to the stages there's
nothing left there's nothing left for me
to put on the meter I can't put the
heating on because I haven't got any
money left this week
the UK is the only G7 country with a
smaller economy than before the pandemic
and inflation is at its highest in 40
years the pandemic and war in Ukraine
are undeniably at fault but brexit and
recent political mismanagement of
stifled hopes of a fast economic
recovery the result more people relying
on the kindness of strangers to meet
their basic needs leave Barker Al
Jazeera Oxfordshire